it was a wedding decades in the making
between
two former new jersey college classmates
they say they could never have imagined
it greg and janet debes were married
earlier this month
in a socially distant ceremony on the
montclair state university football
field
the very same spot where nearly 30 years
ago
they were crowned the school's
homecoming king and queen
errol barnett now on their unlikely
royal
reunion so here i am just swiping away
and i've come across his profile 48 year
old janet de beast didn't realize that
swiping right on a dating app
wasn't just a potential love connection
it was really
a reconnection he was like janet is that
you
and i was just like shut up and i was
like oh my god i'm like that's greg
[Applause]
that was janet back in 1992 becoming
homecoming queen
at montclair state university in new
jersey
and the guy getting mobbed by his
fraternity brothers was her online
connection
greg janet says back then his friends
called him
the beast he was definitely the party
animal
and so greg what about for you what were
your first impressions of janet
beautiful
uh very involved with with school and
then
too good for me by the time they met
online it had been
27 years since greg and janet last saw
each other
they'd both been married had kids and
been divorced
i think it was an instant connection we
just talked as if we had talked
yesterday in the cafeteria at school
in april after more than a year of
dating greg
proposed and on august 1st with
montclair state's endorsement
they made it official on the 50-yard
line
on the same exact spot they were
coronated all those years ago
the ring bearer school mascot rocky the
red hawk
boy did you get your tuitions worth huh
yeah right
no kidding a fitting fairy tale ending
between beauty
and a man once known as the beast for
cbs this morning
i'm errol barnett